>> Sendra: FOX NEWS ALERT,
PRESIDENT TRUMP NAMING ADVISORS
WHO WILL GUIDE EFFORTS TO REOPEN
THAT U.S. ECONOMY IS ALL 50
STATES ARE NOW UNDER A DISASTER
DECLARATION FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN HISTORY.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS IS LIVE WITH MORE
ON ALL OF THAT.
GOOD MORNING, JOHN.
>> GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
IF WE WILL GIVE YOU THE LATEST
ON THE NEW COUNSEL TO REOPEN
AMERICA.
WHEN IT COMES TO REOPENING THE
UNITED STATES ECONOMY, THE
DECISION WILL BE HIS AND HIS
ALONE.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETING FOR THE
PURPOSE OF CONFLICT AND
CONFUSION SOME OF THE FAKE NEWS
MEDIA ARE SAYING THAT IT’S A
GOVERNOR’S DECISION TO OPEN UP
THE STATES, NOT THAT OF THE
PRESIDENT AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
LET IT BE FULLY UNDERSTOOD THAT
THIS IS INCORRECT AND IT IS THE
DECISION OF THE PRESIDENT AND
FOR MANY GOOD REASONS.
THIS WILL CONTINUE A DECISION BY
ME IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
GOVERNORS AND INPUT FOR OTHERS
WILL BE MADE SHORTLY.
THE MAKEUP AND THE CREATION OF
HIS NEW COUNSEL TO REOPEN
AMERICA, AND IT LOOKS LIKE AT
THIS POINT THERE ARE ONLY
GOVERNMENT PEOPLE WHO ARE
INVOLVED IN THIS.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHO WILL BE
ON THE COUNCIL WILL BE CHAIRED
BY MARK MEADOWS.
AND ROBERT LIGHTHIZER, THE U.S.
TRADE REPRESENTATIVE, AND THE
OMB DIRECTOR AND THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE COUNCIL OF ECONOMIC ADVISORS
ALONG WITH A COUPLE OF OTHER
PEOPLE.
THE NEXT SOFT TARGET FOR
REOPENING IS NOW MAY THE 1ST.
REPRESENTATIVE STEVEN HAN SAYS
IT’S ONE THAT WILL ULTIMATELY
DEPEND ON CONDITIONS BEING RIGHT
FOR REOPENING.
LISTEN HERE.
>> IT IS A TARGET AND WE ARE
HOPEFUL ABOUT THE TARGET BUT
IT’S TOO EARLY TO BE ABLE TO
TELL THAT.
WE SEE LIGHT AT THE END OF THE
TUNNEL.
DR. FAUCI AND DR. BROOKS HAVE
SAID THAT AND THE INCREDIBLE
RESILIENCY OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WITH RESPECT TO A SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
IT’S BECOME THE PRESIDENT SAID
LAST FRIDAY THAT MAKING THE
DECISION ON WHAT TO DO WILL BE
THE MOST DIFFICULT DECISION HE
HAS EVER FACED EVER, AND PETER
NAVARRO SAYS IT’S A DIFFICULT
CALCULUS BECAUSE THERE ARE
ENORMOUS PRESSURES ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE EQUATION.
LISTEN HERE.
>> WE KNOW THAT THE VIRUS ITSELF
KILLS BUT ECONOMIC RECESSIONS
AND DEPRESSIONS KILL SO THAT
VERY TOUGH DECISION THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO BE MAKING
WILL HAVE TO WEIGH THE BALANCE
AND FIGURE OUT WHICH PATH DOES
MORE DAMAGE.
>> OF THE PRESIDENT CONTINUED TO
PUSH BACK AGAINST REPORTS THAT
HE IGNORED WARNINGS IN LATE
JANUARY FROM NAVARRO AND OTHERS
OF THE VIRUS COULD BE
DEVASTATING IF IT WERE TO SPREAD
WIDELY IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE TWO PRESIDENT POINTING OUT
HIS EARLY MOVE TO STOP TRAVEL
FROM CHINA WAS IMPORTANT BUT
ALSO TWEETED "I WAS CRITICIZED
FOR RENT MOVING TOO FAST.
THEY TOLD ME NOTHING UNTIL LATER
IN THE PETER NAVARRO MEMO WAS
THE SAME AS THE BAND.
YOU SEE HIS STATEMENT IS FAKE
NEWS.
THE PRESIDENT IS LIKELY TO COMIC
EXPECTED TO LEAVE THE
CORONAVIRUS DAILY BRIEFING AT
5:00, AND I WILL LIKELY LEARN
MORE ABOUT THE MAKEUP OF THE
COUNCIL AND WHAT HE EXPECTS TO
HAPPEN AND WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO BEGIN REOPENING
THE GOVERNMENT IN JUST A LITTLE